what water it's best not to disturb her
so whatever they don't want us to know
about for a show that's set entirely
underground Silo has had a lot of
references to water at the end of
episode 2 Juliet was terrified by the
large body of water under the silo that
George was convinced held an important
secret at the end of episode 3 Jules
nearly drowned when she used water to
keep the temperature down long enough to
finish the repairs on the generator in
episode 6 ended with her being blown
away by a photo of the ocean that
picture turns out to be connected to
Gloria a character we haven't seen or
heard from since she asked Allison if
she really thought she was the kind of
person they want to have children it
turns out we haven't seen her because
she's been sent to Medical for long-term
care that appears to consist of her
being zonked on sedatives for the rest
of her life when she misses a dose she
starts talking about the water that they
don't want us to know about and when
tools goes to see her she delivers the
episode's biggest reveal when she says
that after the Rebellion they put
something in the water so that memories
will fade is this something that's
really happening she just kind of says
it and it slips by with everything else
that's going on but that idea of a they
or them someone behind the scenes
pulling the strings is something that is
all over this episode when this comes
from someone like Gloria or Regina you
may be questioned The Source it sounds a
little conspiratorial but when judge
Meadows who's supposed to be one of the
most powerful people in the silos says
it you kind of have to pay attention as
viewers we know a little bit more than
Jules for instance we know that when she
sees that her vase in her apartment is
missing that someone removed it so they
could see what she was doing in there we
know that there are people in a room
full of screens keeping tabs on the
citizens through cameras that are hidden
behind their mirrors and after episode 7
we know that that room is behind the
Janitor's Closet door and that Sims was
probably the person they were talking
about waking up at the end of the last
episode episode 7 picks up right where
that left off Jules finds Gloria's name
in the Georgia travel guide she
remembers seeing her name from an
interview Holston left in the folder
that he hid in the vent and she goes to
her office to look into her seeing the
book has changed things for the sheriff
and she's on a mission to learn more
about it she blows off a meeting with
the mayor she leaves Billings in charge
and when she finds out Gloria is
essentially in a haze from her mandated
medical treatment she goes to confront
judge Meadows who she learns is out of
the office with a cold in the process of
all this she turns off her radio and she
misses a call to respond to a fight so
when she gets back to the office
Billings gives her an ultimatum to come
clean and surprisingly she just tells
them what's going on she tells him that
George was murdered as was was John's
marns and Trumbull and she's asking him
to look the other way which sets up his
chance to be surprising when he gives
her a way to re-examine George's case
using The Pact in a way that is
connected to their new relics
investigation this makes it clear that
they're starting to become a team and
the only thing he asks in return at this
moment is for her to promise to see the
mayor then she sends him home but asks
where Meadows lives and he tells her and
also tells her if she wants to get on
the judge's good side then bring her
breakfast before any of that plays out
she runs into Lucas in the cafeteria and
finds out that he works in I.T that
leads her to asking about his boss
Bernard and then they talk about the
Stars again and that leads to him moving
in for a kiss she's receptive at first
but then pulls away and leaves without
really telling him what's going on and
then later we see her looking at a page
about the stars in the book she does go
to meet Bernard and he tells her that
the judge didn't appreciate his
Intervention when Sims was trying to
pull her up about the Pez dispenser now
he's worried that she's trying to make a
move against him which seems a little
bit out of left field based on what
we've seen from the judge but this comes
down to Jules perspective of whether or
not she can trust Bernard because if he
can be trusted he would certainly know
more about Judge Meadows and her
motivations he proposes a plan of them
getting something they can use to keep
her from taking over essentially from
what we can see Jules appears to take
him at his word and mentions that she's
working on something that might be
useful but she can't tell him what that
is according to the Pact
she does follow Billings advice and
takes breakfast to Meadows who tries to
send her away when she brings up
blocking up citizens and drugging them
against their will she eventually lets
her in inside her apartment we see that
she has a bunch of relics there's an
extra sketch and a ring Frisbee and
Jules also sees that she's mixing a
drink in the morning so this idea that
she's not feeling well that she has a
cold is all to cover up her alcoholism
as far as we can tell Jules tries to
reason with her she makes her an offer
that if she lifts the medical order she
has to keep Gloria drugged so that she
can ask her about what she said to
Allison then she'll quit being Sheriff
by the end of the week Meadows contends
that she can't do this and she adds that
they will never let you find out the
truth she doesn't say anything more but
it's clear that she's afraid of whoever
they are and there's no way that she can
be convinced to help you see that Sims
is eavesdropping on this conversation
and he finds out that Jules visited
Gloria this is interesting for a couple
of reasons one it doesn't seem like
anybody is above being watched by the
cameras I suppose you could make the
argument that judge Meadows is
compromised but at the same time it
doesn't seem like there's anyone to stop
Sims and I think we should also think
about the fact that he probably answers
to someone else which is interesting
because that means that anyone who isn't
directly involved in whatever's going on
behind that Janitor's Closet door has to
be afraid of the people who are back
there Jules goes to her father's place
because he's a doctor and she thinks he
might be able to help her get Gloria out
for a couple of hours she sees her
brother's stuffed animal on the
bookshelf which signals that he has
regrets about the past and as the
episode progresses we see that his story
is more complicated than we initially
thought at first he tries to talk Jewels
out of going after Gloria but because of
their past she's able to shame him into
helping her they work out a plan that
has him sneaking into the ward saying
that he needs to get into the medicine
cabinet he just needs some aspirin then
he goes into Gloria's room where he sees
which sedative she's on he brings her to
the nursery where Jules is waiting and
tells her that she can't really ask her
any questions because she's out of it
Jules insists that they are doing this
to her and she needs to find out why and
even though it's a bad idea her father
agrees to give her a different drug to
reverse the effects of the sedative this
leads to a seizure which reminds Jules
of her brother and sets up a situation
where they have to wait while they're
doing that we see Sims enter the
Janitor's Closet and we see how the room
with the monitors is hidden we find out
that there are blind spots in the camera
coverage so they can't see where they're
at right now this is curious because it
seems to indicate that they can't make
new cameras when the old ones break
because of that they've been repurposing
cameras from medical for years and while
we can see that there's still a lot of
cameras in The Silo that there are
screens filled with people doing things
everywhere there are some places they
can't see while they wait for Gloria to
wake up Jules and her father have a
conversation we see that she's still
very cold with him and that she hasn't
gotten over what happened when she was a
kid when he goes out to get a cup of
coffee Gloria does wake up and Jules
asked her about Allison though she's
still out of it and she can't really
remember details very well when her
father comes back Gloria recognizes him
and says that he works for them accusing
him of stopping her from having a baby
Gloria is freaked out by his presence
and doesn't seem to trust Jules either
until she shows her the book this is
something she recognizes right away and
we find out that she gave it to George's
mom she describes her as one of us one
of the flame Keepers a group of people
who wanted to keep the memory of the
world before The Silo alive and that was
something that the powers that be were
opposed to apparently so opposed that
since the Rebellion 140 years ago
they've been trying to erase the past
and anyone who tried to preserve it this
is where she brings up the idea of
drugging the water which doesn't seem to
work on everyone based on the fact that
she's in medical loaded to the gills on
sedatives and that's why they didn't
remove her birth control device or
Allison's there are certain traits in
certain people that they want to die off
Jules finds out when she asks her dad
that he didn't remove the birth control
because he was told it was for long-term
survival it was an effort to prevent
genetic diseases from running rampant
which would probably make sense to a
doctor but he says that he always
wondered if they wanted to punish the
ones they picked but he was too afraid
to ask any questions this all seems
really important George's mom was the
last flame keeper Glory area knew so she
gave her her most treasured Relic but
then she died not long after that this
recontextualizes George's obsession with
relics and what he was trying to do and
this probably isn't lost on Jewels we
also find out that his mom knew her mom
and that Gloria thinks that she was
helping her with some type of magnifying
device and that Gloria was always
surprised that they let a woman like
Hannah Nichols have children she wasn't
an official flame keeper but she says
that she shared the same curiosity this
stands out because there's a moment when
Jules and her father are talking where I
think she implies that he betrayed her
mother but I don't think we know how yet
because what Gloria says makes me wonder
if he might have ignored his orders to
leave her birth control in since we know
they had two children together it all
hints that there still are some things
we don't know about what happened before
she ran away to Mechanical the episode
ends at she takes Gloria back and lets
her see the book one more time as
they're talking she mentions that
Holston visited and brought flowers and
Juliet finally puts it together that
they can watch them through the mirrors
she decides to cover the one in that
room and then checks the vent because
Gloria said that Holston was working on
it and she finds the hard drive Sims
wants to know what's happening and when
his crew says that the problem is that
they only have audio he points out that
the real problem is that she knows that
they have cameras and he tells them to
send in the Raiders this is a SWAT like
group that is ready and waiting and they
take off to head to Gloria's room there
she tells Jules that she's the last
flame keeper now she says that she
didn't ask for this it's not fair but it
is down to her and if she lets it die
the truth will die too it's all a bit
much in Jules is somewhat reluctant but
he asked her what her mom would want her
to do and then she asks her do you know
why she killed herself and we don't get
to see what happens next the Raiders
bust in they asked where she is we see
that she already laughed that she was a
little bit ahead of them and the episode
ends as it cuts to Black
I thought this was a really good episode
especially the second time I watched it
and it also has the distinction of being
the one where having read the series is
really causing me to hold back in
relation to speculating on what will
happen next as I've been saying I think
the show is doing a commendable job
adapting the book and the Ripple effects
from changes they made early on have now
created a situation where I can't say
for sure what's going to happen next but
while details have changed it's still
fundamentally the same so it's
impossible to discuss the questions I
have in a way that's disconnected from
what I know I tried to think back to
where my head was when I first read the
book and this idea of a they of someone
who is controlling things started to
become more apparent I think what I kept
coming back to was the motivation behind
it that is to say why is The Silo set up
this way what is anyone trying to
accomplish through these deceptions how
was this decided and how how did it come
down because what we see is that there's
this guy Sims who has a lot of power and
from what he told Trumbull this was
apparently passed down from his father
but surely this isn't some independent
Shadow Dynasty it feels built into
something larger he plays a role in an
organization or a cabal or something
right like it doesn't feel like he's the
Undisputed ruler of The Silo verse or
whatever right so then questions about
who is in on it who knows what he does
what are they trying to accomplish and
who answers to who these questions all
inevitably come up the key example here
is Sims using judge Meadows as his
puppet that should make you question
everything you know about the power
structure which is almost confusing at
this point Bernard appears to fear
Meadows but she's just doing what Sims
says so what does that mean about
Bernard shutting Sims down when he tried
to remove jewels in the last episode is
this just regular jockeying for power is
it just politics when Jules first came
up it seemed like Bernard and Sims were
on the same wavelength working together
and even before that when they were
trying to convince John's to make
Billings the next Sheriff was that just
an arrangement of convenience because
they both are interested in maintaining
order or is it something more and to
bring it back to the water I was talking
about in the beginning of the video
there's an exchange between Jules and
Bernard where he brings up water as he's
talking about how important his job in
it is Jules thinks it's the generator
that keeps The Silo running but he
points out that all the invisible
functions that it does like transmitting
messages circulating the air and
watering the crops are controlled by his
servers if those were to fall into the
wrong hands it wouldn't matter that the
generator was cranking out power I feel
like this reframes their role somewhat
since the name it makes them sound like
the guys you call when your computer is
acting up that mention of watering the
crops makes it seem like you would need
access to those servers if you were
planning on doing something like putting
something in the water supply to make
people forget the introduction of the
Raiders was curious too I guess those
guys work for judicial and not the
secret organization in the Janitor's
Closet but I mean we've heard the
citizens were on edge and we saw actual
fighting in this episode where they
didn't bring these guys out why haven't
we seen these guys yet the way they show
up at Medical gives the impression that
regular citizens know they exist but
that they also only bring them out in
very specific situations another thing
is the idea that no one knows for sure
about the cameras Billings and jewels
refer to the listeners and the friends
of The Silo which is kind of funny since
everyone is looking at everyone else as
a potential snitch but it's probably
just the cameras that can see inside
their Apartments
her dad who has worked with some of
these people behind the scenes even had
the sense that they couldn't listen
inside the nursery but it didn't seem
like he knew for sure how it worked and
I gotta say it was nice to see them
filling in some of the blanks related to
his story as I mentioned before I think
there's still more to discover there I
mean we did find out that her mother
committed suicide if you think back to
those flashbacks it skips over from when
her brother was having the seizures to
where they're both not around anymore so
there's more to understand there which
may be related to what Gloria was saying
about this magnifying glass that she was
working on but at the very least there's
more that we don't understand about what
Jules blames her father for and if
there's things that she doesn't know
about what really happened and to wrap
it up it's pretty hard to figure out how
discovering these things that Jules did
in this episode like the cameras and the
judge Meadows is just an alcoholic who
is having problems keeping things
together and she really answers The Sims
it's pretty hard to see how she can turn
this around and not end up like John's
and morons If there really is an effort
to eliminate people who remember things
I don't see how you can go forward with
a sheriff who has seen this book who
knows that there's something going on
behind the scenes so it'll be
interesting to see how Sims reacts to
this in the next episode and I think
that is a pretty great place to leave
things please like this video If you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon